my son lives here and I'm the
best-selling author of this book come
closer boil over and holler if you
haven't read this you are an idiot
what is this video about in this video I
want to talk to you about some of the
predictions I made a year to three years
ago where the market is at right now and
where it's going in the future so stay
tuned tell you what is your job and my
job is to source everything that you
would buy absolutely
she's to bring me some really good
houses HMOs single let's go internet
properties by the flips that are so good
that I asked it's one worth in the
business full-time here at the glorious
Hilton Hall two years ago we were
sourcing houses right we were sourcing
houses HMO properties for myself to buy
and for other investors to buy and they
were properties that were around about
85,000 pounds up to a hundred thousand
pounds for four beds hey Tomas okay in
Wolverhampton
Walsall Dudley areas what that today in
2018 not only how price has gone up
considerably I'm looking at the screen
right now I can't find a house within 20
miles of Wolverhampton that's less than
one thousand pound even if it's a three
bed house more affordable house this is
just insane so okay so right move
now this isn't like clever clever stuff
this is off on just online do you want
write news and you type in say
Wolverhampton can you see the screen of
Elliott yeah cool
so price range we're gonna go minimum to
a hundred thousand pounds three bedrooms
property type houses let's see what
we've got 26 results and of those 26
results
all of them are like auctions okay at 95
Oh surprise surprise but only showing
two cash buyers why probably because
there's what what's wrong with the house
mine shaft then there's this one let's
have a look at this one 95 I know but
forget if it doesn't hate you man there
probably will be something wrong with it
probably look at the damp on picture
wall so here's my point
he's on the point they're all houses
available for less than a hundred grand
there are just three bed houses forget
extra modes to get four beds through the
hunters in one they just don't exist so
here's my point right now if you are
watching this video and you bought a
house from Tanya there was a four-bed
HMO in Wolverhampton a year or two ago I
think you owe 10 you're drinking 1,400
pounds rent a month 1,400 a month rent
because it would mean that you could HMO
but even if you didn't get quite that
much or even if you did on top of that
your house now will probably be worth
130 140 150 160 right bye that was
Wolverhampton let's look at Birmingham
so Birmingham okay Birmingham city
centre
let's do with them let's do within a
mile price range no minimum up to a
hundred thousand three bed and we're
looking at houses so three bit house
let's see what we got we've got three
results so there's three out of those
results there will be no service right
look this one is an auction so that will
go for a lot more than a hundred this
one is offers over and it's abortion and
this one is also
auctions so come I come in so there's
only three out three houses in the whole
of Birmingham that are it's just notice
we have anything that just proves your
point you've been drilling into
investors for years and years and years
and it proves that we are sourcing
really big and by the way guys this is
being post the bricks it announcements
so all those people that were saying
move up practicing what about houses
into speaking up and up and up so what
does this mean to you today I guess this
means that the 25 grand a room thing you
know I sent my book yeah 25 grand a room
that is completely not the case anymore
busy talking in the Midlands I'm sorry
right now you're probably talking about
a 35 gram bedroom in the Midlands so it
could still stop because another thing
that's shot up like crazy is rent so the
Midlands have just gone now you could
invest in the Midlands right now if you
want you're not going to have to do a
lot used to two to two years ago you can
invest in the Midlands or you can invest
a little bit further north when this is
going to happen again because the thing
is everywhere follows London so this
happened in London five years ago five
years ago in London houses have doubled
in London in the last seven years in
some parts now I will see me happening
it's kind of happened in parts of the
Midlands it's gonna happen up north so
if you're right now buying a house in
Grimsby Middlesbrough where else I'm
thinking more rent out I think you're
okay I think you're okay I've got houses
in those areas myself but on top of that
what's the capital appreciation over the
next few years
boom and you'll owe us a drink anyway
that's me dough today so investing
property you get paid twice in property
once and capture appreciation once in
rent remember more importantly
invest in yourself figure this stuff out
immerse yourself in property immerse
yourself in education
god bless I'll see you next time
[Music]